what I have here is an account of an
exam taken by Terence Tau one of the
world's best mathematicians while he was
in graduate school what's interesting
about this exam is that Terence Town
nearly failed this close call could have
thwarted his math career but instead he
says that this near failure is what
propelled him to succeed it was the
results of this exam that made parents
tell stop playing so many video games
and knuckle down and try harder it was
the Princeton General qualifying exams
which Terence took at age 18 after a
year of graduate work at the time around
1993 the Princeton graduate classes
didn't have any homework or tests and
this exam was the one major thing that
you needed to pass in order to proceed
with your PhD it was an oral exam kind
of like an interview where three
professors directly ask questions
taryn's Tao is one one of today's
greatest mathematicians and has won many
awards including a Fields medal on this
channel before I have covered an exam
that he aced as a child prodigy so I was
a little surprised to hear that he had
ever struggled with an exam we know what
questions Terence was asked thanks to a
tradition at Princeton of the students
writing up their memory of the exam
afterwards this serves as a useful tool
for other students wanting to know what
to expect this is what Terence wrote
after his exam my examiners were Stein
kleinemann and redneck kleinerman came
in about five minutes late the first
questions they asked were about harmonic
analysis they asked me what I knew and I
said basically singular integrals and
functional analysis no real harmonic
Theory at all so they examined me on
singular integrals instead for every
math student the general exam will draw
questions from five topics real analysis
complex analysis algebra and then two
topics of the student's Choice probably
what they want to pursue their PHD in
terence's two special topics were
harmonic analysis and analytic number
Theory give examples of singular
integrals Calderon zigmund what theorems
do you know about them and how do you
prove boundedness I stated a TBE theorem
which nobody seemed very acquainted with
and said some brief explanation that
knowing boundedness on L2 was sufficient
to prove it for LP for a p between 1 and
infinity harmonic analysis is the
representation of functions as waves and
includes Fourier transforms the
questions that Terence was asked right
off the bat are Advanced and I don't
understand the answers but that's
because they're on very specific topics
you could make it all the way through a
math undergrad and PhD without ever
encountering Calderon Sigmund results of
singular integrals but these topics are
what Terence has told the examiners he
has prepared for and so that's where
they are guiding the questions since my
TB theorem was Martingale based Stein
asked me to give a definition of
martingales I gave the sigma algebra
purely measure theoretic version but
stumbled a bit on the definition of
conditional expectation I think Stein
was Satisfied by my explanation at the
end though Stein then asked me what
other boundedness theorems I knew I
couldn't think of any concrete ones
offhand but I mumbled about a
convolution operator being bounded if
it's Fourier transform was bounded and
had some smoothness condition but I
couldn't recall any details
it's here that we see things starting to
unravel for Terence at each step going
forwards he is being asked to
demonstrate a complex idea but chokes up
on the details and in providing concrete
examples Terence had studied harmonic
analysis for his master's thesis and
later said that since he felt it was his
strong suit he only spent a few days
reviewing analysis this TB theorem was
part of his master's thesis so he does
okay with questions about it but as soon
as they move away from it his lack of
preparation is starting to show there
were some questions about the
boundedness of the Hilbert operator and
an easy way of proof I said the Fourier
transform was bounded and that should do
it for L2 they seem to be hinting at
generalizations and eventually I clicked
onto Rhys potentials but again I didn't
know enough results only that they were
bounded with this being an oral exam we
see how different it is to open one
there are no set questions and the
examiners are coming up with questions
that respond to terence's answers this
allows them to really find the depth of
his knowledge in topics that he's
supposed to be prepared for the format
can be pretty intimidating at age 18
Terence would have been a few years
younger than his fellow students and had
found math easy ever since he was a
young kid with his natural interest and
talent for the subject he had never had
to try too hard studying for an exam in
the past and in earlier studies could
get by with cramming the textbook a few
days before the exam and spending the
rest of his time just playing with the
ideas that he found most interesting
according to an article he wrote years
later looking back at this exam he said
that he had made it all the way to
Princeton without developing systematic
study habits I was asked for a couple
definitions of H1 I got the atomic
definition right and the race potentials
that got the limit of harmonic functions
definition wrong and I had no idea how
to prove that any of them were
equivalent so they abandoned this after
a while but not until they made me
realize that the latter definition I had
given was actually that of L1 not H1
instead of treating the qualifying exam
as a top priority Terence said that he
spent an embarrassingly large fraction
of his time as a graduate student
messing around online which might be the
most relatable thing I've read about him
yet he discovered the World Wide Web in
his first year and played computer games
until late at night in the graduate
student dormitories computer room while
his fellow classmates did months of
preparation Terence said that he only
did about two weeks worth he might have
been used to getting away with doing
less work than those around him but
natural Talent can only get you so far
and they asked me about fundamental
Solutions I sluffed the exponents in the
denominator a few times so they began
asking me about homogeneity eventually
with a lot of prodding I got the
exponents of the Newtonian and kaushi
potentials correctly here the examiners
are asking easier and easier questions
to try and get him to a point where he's
able to give a satisfactory answer and
they're walking him through a derivation
of finding the fundamental Solutions of
the laplacian Terence later described
this as painful
to be clear for me none of this is easy
and barely any of the questions are even
comprehensible but I suppose it's
considered easy for someone who has
taken the right coursework kleinerman
asked me about the connections between
pdes and singular integrals but I didn't
know any more than vague generalities
Terence later said that he had enjoyed
playing with harmonic analysis for its
own sake but had never paid much
attention to how it was used in other
fields such as pdes this was the All Is
Lost moment but terence's luck was about
to change and they switched to analytic
number Theory surprisingly I feared much
better on this topic in a stroke of luck
only one of the three examiners had an
extensive background in number Theory
but had mistakenly thought that
terence's second special topic was
algebraic number Theory instead of
analytic number Theory and after
realizing his mistake he wasn't able to
use any of the difficult algebraic
number Theory questions which he had
prepared because that wasn't what
Terence needed to be tested on so
instead Terence was given just the
standard analytic number Theory
questions which weren't that difficult
Rudnick mainly asked give several forms
of the zeta function give one that
allows analytic continuation prove the
modularity of the Theta function and
thus derive the functional equation what
do you know about the poles and zeros
analytic number theory is using the
methods of analysis to study number
Theory the Riemann zeta function is
perhaps the most famous example where a
complex analysis is used to study the
distribution of prime numbers State a
form of the prime number theorem
throughout I didn't have to back up
anything with Messy calculations redneck
always stopped me when I tried
talk about primes and arithmetic
progressions give an elementary proof of
the infinitude of primes of the form 4N
minus 3. these were more standard
questions which Terence had prepared for
and so breezed through them the prime
number one is funny because Terence
later went on to prove quite a famous
theorem about prime number progressions
which are a series of numbers which are
equally spaced for example 3 7 and 11
constitute a progression of prime
numbers where the gap between each
number is four
Terence Tao and Ben green proved that it
is always possible to find somewhere in
the Infinity of integers a progression
of prime numbers of equal spacing and
any length what algebraic tools are used
in durashley's proof of infinitude of
primes and arithmetic progressions it
took a while before I understood oh you
want me to talk about characters then
they asked how duration got an explicit
formula for this when chai was a real
character I was going to write a messy
but finite expression involving signs
and logs but then realized that they
were talking about the class number
formula I said carelessly though that
this was a disgusting way to do it since
I was still thinking about the sine log
formulas then they made a comment that
this would put thousands of people out
of work or something like that anyway I
stated what the class number was vaguely
but didn't give out an explicit equation
again redneck wave me off when I tried
this and I seemed satisfied it seems
like here that Terence has accidentally
insulted anybody who uses the class
number theorem but when he said it was
disgusting it was because he was
thinking about writing out some other
messy expression a nice awkward
miscommunication but maybe they all
laughed about it then redneck asked a
few algebra questions only and it was
over talk about galwa Theory what do you
know about an what other simple groups
do you know the monster but I backed
down quickly saying I knew not how to
define it in the discussion meandered a
bit as the professors talked among
themselves about whether the group of
order 168 which I mentioned was sporadic
after this they decided to barely pass
me though they said that my harmonic
analysis was far from satisfactory they
didn't ask any real or complex analysis
but I guess from my handling of the
special topics they decided that wasn't
necessary besides we were almost getting
snowed in the exam lasted two hours
after the exam Stein who was his thesis
advisor told Terrence that he was
disappointed that his letters of
recommendation had been strong and this
wasn't what he was expecting
Terrence said that this moment left him
in a State of Shock because it was the
first time he had done poorly on an exam
that he had been genuinely interested in
doing well in it's not the first time he
had done poorly on an exam in fact he
had failed two of them back in undergrad
but one was for a Fortran class where he
had refused to learn it on the basis
that he already knew how to program in
basic and the other one was a quantum
mechanics class where Terence ignored
the warning that he would have to write
an essay about the history of the
subject during the final exam and he had
to be escorted from that final exam in
tears he said that the Princeton General
exam was a wake-up call and a turning
point in his career he began to take
studying and his classes more seriously
because he had finally seen consequences
for not studying I listened more to my
fellow students and other faculty and I
cut back on my gaming I worked
particularly hard on all the problems
that my advisor gave me in the hopes of
finally impressing him in retrospect
nearly failing the generals was probably
the best thing that could have happened
to me at the time being told that his
harmonic analysis was unsatisfactory is
kind of funny now because Terence Tower
was awarded the fields medal for his
contributions to partial differential
equations
combinatorics harmonic analysis and
additive number Theory either he did
become a lot better at harmonic analysis
or these exams are not great at
measuring one's ability to get a Fields
medal reading about Terence tau's
struggles with this exam is I'm sure
comforting to anyone who has struggled
with a test it's a reminder that tests
themselves don't say too much about your
potential but instead did what's more
important is what you do after getting a
bad result it also shows that really
dedicated and intelligent people can
sometimes mess up opportunities by
overestimating their own ability or
assuming they can Coast by purely on
natural Talent Terence tau is a top-tier
mathematician because of his creativity
in problem solving and in coming up with
new mathematics these aren't skills that
are being tested on a qualifying exam
but experience and being well read also
matter Terence himself says that one
does not need a genius Gene to become a
mathematician Talent is important of
course but how one develops and nurtures
it is even more so
this video is sponsored by male science
whose kits can help nurture curious
Young Minds
this is a cycloid drawing machine and
different combinations of the gears give
rise to different mesmerizing patterns a
gear with 60 teeth and a gear with 20
teeth have a ratio of three to one and
draw out a cycloid with three Loops for
every full spin of the large gear other
combinations will create different
shapes some of which we see in nature
drawing machine is from the art of math
kit it's from the Mel math subscription
which aims to change kids perceptions of
math and Inspire them with ideas that
they might not encounter at school the
math subscription is new and a part of
the Mel science line which includes
monthly boxes on stem physics chemistry
and medicine for kids from Age 5 to 16
plus the out of math kit also contains a
puzzle to explore the principles of
tessellation and Kevin Lieber from
vsauce2 provides guidance alongside the
projects through the mail science app to
keep the concepts accessible and fun I
think that these kits make for great
gifts for young people and have the
potential to inspire a lifelong interest
in science if you'd like to try them out
you can get 50 off your first month of
any mail Science subscription by using
my code tibies that link will be down in
the description thanks smell science and
thanks to my patreon supporters for
making these videos possible a special
shout out to today's patreon cat of the
day Hari Krishna
[Music]